well hi how are you my name is Kol is
here hello I'm shamanic Rao sir we've
come from Chile to this lovely town of
eyes now but uh conocer look we're on
the trail of Johann Sebastian Bach my
favorite composer followed either come
with us paninos llegamos here we are in
from the silhouette I've dreamt of
visiting this house all my life when you
adore me here even now we're here this
is the studio where body composed the
furniture dates from his time just look
at it I booked a meeting
moc own an emotional even though I'm not
as much of an aficionado as Claudio I
find it very interesting in Thedas
santisimo anyway I'm gonna take a
picture of you now oh yeah yeah
estoy absolute Amin I'm absolutely
overwhelmed by the emotions i'm
experiencing right now I feel really
fortunate to be allowed to be here in
this house for me it's a dream come true
kuya lugar para me hace un verdadero
socho realidad
really look at the church what's its
name if they listen this is st. George's
Church it played an important role in
box story he was baptized here I Adiba
porque él fue a volte sol aquí
I
in solo a Talib inside I'm very moved
when I think about johann Sebastian
Bach's body being held over the
baptismal font it's a hugely emotional
moment for me significa una mo co nguoi
grande para me donde we arguin amo ser
las afuera we're on the outskirts of
eyes enough with a beautiful view of the
city that's with that look honey I
thought you were castle mmm we have to
visit it don't you think of course let's
go
hey hey this is not about castle what a
beautiful place beautiful
na po ay khuda a hundred percent of the
ceiling is decorated there isn't a
single again exactly
it done / feathers mosaic is simply
perfect you think it was a painting
because there are so many details but if
you look closely it's all made up of
tiny pieces of different colors y todo
it's impressive working at rosso de que
tal de tanto calor y impression until
tahoe it does had a marvelous day we've
explored eyes enough and box birthplace
but eyes now has much more to offer than
bah anyone there are lots of other
places to discover like this one the
work like this one rosberg castle if I
won't go to the uh goodbye for now but
all of you should come to eyes enough
and get to know it as well ideals